this property is not owned by me it's
not owned by any of my students it's
controlled by one of my students thomas
how old are you tom i'm 18 years old
he's 18 years old hey what's up my
name's samuel leeds and right now i want
to introduce you to a guy who's 18 years
old his name's tom and he is completely
financially free by a direct result of
following my strategies in property so
tom welcome to the show hi thanks for
having me samuel so you are literally 18
years old yeah true or false okay you
are now making more money than your
teachers at school yep
true
you left school college whatever at 18
yeah never have to have a job in your
life no
that sounds
i know it does i kind of have to pinch
myself sometimes a little bit but yeah
that's the facts so talk to me about how
this started when did you start watching
the videos and what happened so i
started watching the videos in september
of 2020 a lot longer no so i was
um managed to get away for a holiday
and i just started scrolling on youtube
came across your videos
um
and just binged watched all words loads
of 17 at the time yeah right
and i thought well these are
these are great i didn't like
know that you could do all these
different types of things with property
um
and
yeah after that i booked onto the online
crash course yeah that you did in
february and that's when i learned about
uh rent to rent which is what was my
first deal was you're right um so i
learned that and all the different
strategies that you can do and it was
about 10 hours but it i was glued for
every single second of the whole video
um stream it was great and you've also
you know you went on to do advanced
training which you paid for yourself yes
out of your basically money that you'd
worked for as a teenager while at school
while studying um so did it stink to pay
for education
it did it initially i was kind of like
oh well if
don't put the effort in afterwards don't
take action then um i'm gonna have put a
lot of money uh down the drain but
thankfully watching the videos not only
does it um teach you everything but kind
of hold you accountable as well you kind
of meet loads of people at these
training things
and it really motivated me to want to go
find deals and stuff so like after the
online course that i did i did a little
bit watch some more of your videos on
rent to rent and then within about two
weeks afterwards i um i'd be i'd listed
the first renter hmm that i got in
huddersfield amazing so first thing i
want to say is mad congratulations
because what you've done is remarkable
and a lot of you know teenagers 18 year
olds wouldn't even dream of taking the
kind of action that you've taken i know
it's not been easy you've got to get
rejected you've gone into estate agents
you've been on the phone you've been
hustling but the fact that now you've
got um a rental rent yeah you've got a
lease option agreement service
accommodation you've packaged and sold a
deal recently yeah um and and what's
your like how much last month for
instance did you make in profit from
your rent to rent and lease option
agreement uh so from the rent to rent
and the lease option agreement last
month um i made just over two grand so
about two thousand two hundred twelve
exactly two thousand two hundred and
fifty grand last month two to two
thousand two hundred pounds clean profit
yep one month yeah from a rent to rent
and a lease option agreement and that
doesn't include packaging that's just a
pure
rent coming in um which is an average
salary yeah that's like incredible so
what i want to do in this video is i
want you to break down a few things
firstly i want to talk to you about the
strategy how you did it
what a rent to rent is what a lease
option agreement is what service
accommodation is how you did it what
area you've done it in and i really want
to go through the a to z so that people
watching this maybe can
skip some of the hardships on youtube
they can copy it paste it and do the
same watching the video so first things
first
um rent to rent that was your first deal
yeah first deal how did you find it what
happened
so the rent to rent initially i spent a
lot of time phoning agents getting
rejected although we don't know what a
company like is we don't know what rent
to rent is leave us alone firm down i
was like oh picked up the phone again
just kept going and going and going and
going
and
i had to go for no
every time what does that mean what does
go for no means so don't expect
yes don't expect them to buy oh yes we
do do company likes corporate let's rent
to rent don't expect that um and just
keep ringing the phone the more times
you're in the phone the more likely you
are to getting right but that's a really
big lesson straight away rather than
ringing up and thinking i hope they say
yes i hope they say yes it says and then
they say no you go oh rejected and you
quit yeah if you think actually they
probably will say no and guess what
that's part of the game hey my name is
tom da da um i'm looking to rent this
property it would be a corporate letter
i wouldn't be living there myself and if
they go whoa we don't do corporate let's
pee
you go well i expected that to happen
anyway yeah and then you pick up the
phone again and then you pick up the
phone again so how many how many people
did you speak to before you had someone
that said yeah i'm open
i must have made about 20 phone calls
20 30 phone calls before i got a yes
rejection rejection rejection rejection
what was it that kept me going through
the rejections
knowing that
if i did keep ringing and i've followed
kind of
scripts or maybe
what i'd seen on videos that you done
and how to talk to the agents make sure
you say the right things because that's
really important if you kind of pick up
the firm without any confidence not
knowing exactly what you're going to say
and kind of wing it
if you've not done it before it's really
hard to get that conversation going yeah
so
picking up the phone knowing what to say
being polite with confidence
um
expecting nurm and then obviously
eventually after the 30 calls i got a
yes which was fantastic amazing so that
first agent that was like yes this is
something we're open to
um you're based where huddersfield
you're always in huddersfield and you're
trying to convince me that huddersfield
is a great holiday destination
i'm not sure about that one still
huddersfield or hawaii i'm not sure but
we'll get there so this first house in
huddersfield yeah um what was it what
was it currently being used as so it was
currently just being used as a single
let it was advertised as two bedrooms
but it had a reception room and a loft
right so they had the floor plan um on
their website and i thought well that's
easily one two that's four rooms
yes so um how do you turn a sitting room
into a bedroom put a bed in it yes
so you see this two bedroom for rent how
much was it on for rent uh 575 pounds a
month
five seven five and you're thinking well
hold on a minute
rooms are renting for like 400 pound a
month i could rent both rooms out and
the sitting room and the loft and i
could get about what fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred pounds it yeah that's
how much i mean i'm gonna pay the
landlord i'm gonna pay the bills i'll be
left with a
ka-ching some nice passive income for me
550 a month profit so that profits you
550 a month yep setting it up i mean
dude man i came out to the house i've
seen the house
you had to paint it yourself
you had to furnish it how much money did
you have to put to get that property
um so i didn't actually pay a deposit on
the property how did you get how did you
get around that
uh
sweet talking kind of i just kind of
said well
um it's great as it is but this is as a
single let but this is what i want to do
i'm gonna have to need to paint i'm
gonna have to need to put in furniture
in four rooms which isn't cheap i'm
gonna have to get a carpet putting in
the loft
um and then they i was kind of like well
come on then and then they were like
yeah go for it and then um i had to pay
five seven five um the day that i signed
so up front yep up front
um and then the furnishings uh for the
beds um and the bedside tables that was
all ikea
um and the carpets and then i painted
myself i started to buy the pen and the
paint brushes and stuff yeah so
cost around 600 pounds all of that yeah
the rent up front five seven fives uh
you're looking at just over a grand
that's not a lot though no no it's not
because it made itself back in two
months so just over a grand
but you had to put some sweat equity in
it because you did a lot of the stuff
yourself yeah um
however
so talk me through the figures 1500 how
long did it take to fill the rooms
um
not long at all maybe
two weeks from when i got the keys two
weeks i know your mom was a little bit
stressed yeah because she was like oh
you've just gone on saturday you need
this course and now you've
rented this house why was if you can't
rent the rooster yeah what does your mom
think uh so she's quite um an
old-fashioned landlady uh she's um her
and my dad have done pretty well in
profit but only really buying uh
properties and renting them out just
single let's got a few hmrs
um but she'd never heard of the concept
of rent to rent so i told all my watch
i've been on samuel lee's online crash
course i've looked at some of the videos
this is like a really good idea for
someone my age that doesn't have a lot
of money or experience
i can you know make a few hundred pounds
a month and i'll also get the experience
of being a landlord
and she was like oh well i've never
heard of this i've been doing this for
18 20 years i've got no idea what this
is are you sure are you sure and i was
like yeah yeah we'll figure it out yeah
did she give you money to get started no
nothing nothing at all so all right so
your mom's a little bit skeptical
you started yourself yeah you put your
own money in yeah from just little side
jobs and stuff while you were studying
you also
do this property did you rent the rooms
yourself yes
no i advertised them all myself on uh
open rent spare room and facebook
marketplace cool which is basically next
to nothing
that's completely free completely free
yeah so you marketed the rooms you
filled them single-handedly yeah you're
then getting a profit of like about 500
something pounds a month what did you
think when you got our first property
the money started coming in um
like i said i kind of have to pinch
myself a little bit like um
i've never really heard of any other 18
year old landlords like people were
paying me money
to
have a roof over their head and i was
kind of like this is not this i was like
a year ago this is not the service that
i think i'd be providing for people yeah
um and then when i started seeing the
money coming in i was like well
where's the next one yeah
now you use the money you reinvested it
you've done um you know you've done
quite a bit of training with myself yes
yes uh how's the training been by the
way it's been fantastic
everything's been
um so informative and to
every dotted every i crossed every t all
the details
um and without the training i wouldn't
be where i am now i wouldn't be sat here
if it wasn't for the training i wouldn't
be financially free
um i wouldn't be able to kind of almost
do what i want when i want now kind of
thing yeah so i'm really grateful for
that oh well thank you for saying and
it's it for me it's it's a great buzz
being able because when i started out i
was 17 i got my first house at 17 and
you know being able to see other young
people win it's it's awesome and you've
taken that you've put a lot of work in
so you have to credit where credit's due
so you then went and got a
property on a lease option agreement yes
which is insane so this lease option
agreement talk me through firstly before
we talk about the cash flow the rent
talk me through how you structured the
deal how much you're going to be paying
for it and why you've agreed to buy in
seven years and not today uh so it came
about just through looking on right move
um looking at the oldest listed
properties so these were prop this was a
property that the landlord could not
sell he'd been trying to sell it for a
while and it just wasn't budging at all
he'd also been renting the property
though so he'd been renting it uh for
the past few years
uh renting that out pretty well
can came to try and sell it and just
could not sell it so you saw this
property you saw that it was for sale
but also for rent yeah and you thought
um this could be a lease option yeah so
the training teaches you that's the kind
of way that you should look for
properties
something that's been on the market for
a while and then it's a bonus if it's
been rented out before as well yeah so
because then you know that it's going to
have a buy to their mortgage yes and
also you know that the landlord wants to
sell it but it's also open to rent it
yeah so he doesn't need the money now
yeah and also tell me for anyone that's
thinking at least option what
what is a lease option agreement so
basically you agreed to buy the property
for a fixed price now
um but you don't actually pay that all
you pay is on the option which could be
as little as one pound so you pay
an option fee as little as one pound
yeah and then you have the right not the
not the obligation but the option to buy
a property
now but pay for it later yes and then in
the meantime you benefit from any
capital appreciation any uplift you also
benefit from any rent that you're
getting on the property you pay the
landlord an agreed monthly fee yes and
so
i have but he has the obligation he has
to he has to sell it basically if i want
to buy it so yes
um he's obliged to sell but i'm not
obliged to buy which is kind of
uh the beauty of the deal and people
might think that's unfair you know why
does he have to sell it
but you have the option to buy it it
doesn't seem fair what would you say um
i would say that well i'm gonna be
the property is gonna be completely off
his hands yeah for the next seven years
right um he's never gonna have any
arrears he's not gonna have to pay any
major repairs
yeah um so i'm completely taking care of
the property for him yes and then he's
gonna get the money for it at the end as
well boom you know what you have grown
so much as a person over the last 12
months thanks
do you feel that i feel if i'd have
asked that question a year ago you'd
have been like oh i don't know
right but now it's just like no because
i'm going to take it off his hand i'm
going to do this yeah um so okay so with
lease option agreement then so you agree
to buy a house now pay for it later
you're taking the property off of the
landlord's hands and you're then renting
out dealing with all the all the issues
he's getting the price that he wants but
you're paying for it on your terms which
is in seven years time yes so this
property then it's worth about 200 grand
yes around the 200 000 pound mark yeah
so you agreed to buy 200 000 pounds yes
and
when do you have to pay for it in seven
years time soon 2028
in 2028 if in 2028 it's not going up in
value you can walk away yeah but you
have the right
to buy it yep for 210 000 yeah is that
what you agreed yeah 210 in 2028 yes
so
you've now got this property under your
control what are you doing with it uh so
i'm renting it out as service
accommodation um
for people that don't know what service
care accommodation is it's airbnb
booking.com right so it's available for
short staycations contractors
people may be in between moving houses
um and they can for whatever reason that
you might want to stay there it's
there so basically
normally when you've got a property you
just rent it out
to a tenant
how much would that house rent out for
if you just rented it to one tenant um
700 pounds a month
how much are you paying the landlord
each month 700 pounds a month so the
landlord is getting 70 pounds a month so
he's getting a guaranteed rent for seven
years
and then a sale at the end of it so
actually he's getting a decent offer but
you
are paying him 700 a month but you've
then rented it instead of rent and
putting a tenant in it you've put it on
airbnb on booking.com you've done it
mint you've burnished it to a beautiful
standard
how much
are you getting in rent on that property
uh so
last month it grossed around three
thousand pounds and netted one thousand
seven fifty
so you are grossing last month alone
three grand yeah you're giving the
landlord in 700 quid yep you're paying
the cleaners the bills whatever yeah you
were left with 1700 pounds clean profit
from that one lease option agreement
yeah dude man that is absolutely insane
so you've got that you've got your
rental rent yeah you also um packaged
and sold a deal recently yeah um i've
also been
project managed a couple of um
properties as well so there was um we
used the buy refurbished refinance
strategy i put a lit i put some money
into that and a lot of sweat equity
so that was a property that was bought
for 60 000 pounds cash
my joint ventured
and we spent ten thousand pounds on it
and it's been revalued at one hundred
and seven thousand five hundred pounds
so we can pull our money out so you're
telling me in the last year you've done
brr
lease option service accommodation rent
to rent and you've done deal sources
yeah you've basically done almost every
strategy
that there is in the property industry
yeah your experience now is through the
roof um the money's now coming in nicely
you never have to work a job ever again
no making more money than your school
teachers
what's your strongest reason what's
giving you the motivation to go out and
do all this because you've worked bloody
hard
um i think i just have an innate
hunger just all the time likes one
thing's never enough like i could i
could sit on my ass all day and do
nothing now
um i've got i'm getting this money in
every month i'll maybe have to answer a
few emails a few messages but
really i just want to scale i just want
more i want to be
in a position where i can start doing
developments and stuff like that or
maybe completely scale and systemize a
sourcing company um
and with my urge and the time that i've
gotten the people that i've met i really
think the the world's my oyster
absolutely really i can really put my
mind into all the different strategies
and uh really like put myself in a good
position in 10 20 years time so
basically you're just building an empire
right now yeah so that down the line
you can do what you want when you want
with whoever you want yeah and that my
like my kids kids kids don't have to
work kind of right generational well
yeah don't ever taught this in school
man i know but you've achieved it so
quickly you know and the great thing is
as well your parents i mean your mom who
was a little bit skeptical about the
rent to rents at first um you know now
she's seeing what you're doing and she's
actually coming to become a student
she's joined my training myself yeah and
she's doing developments and stuff um
but the thing is you know i think having
people around you it's really i'm so
glad that your parents are like yeah
i've seen you winning yeah it will prove
that it works yeah and i'd just like to
say that throughout the whole thing
alongside with the training and support
that i've had from the entire samuel
lee's community my parents have been
sensational in providing support yeah
and giving advice like i said they're
old-fashioned landlords but
completely open to new ideas like now
after seeing the success that i've had
my mum's joined the development training
and she's doing really well with that
yeah i mean if it wasn't for you or for
me taking action on the training she
wouldn't be there um doing that but at
the same time sometimes if i'm feeling a
little bit or this deal didn't go
through she's there to kind of pick me
back up so she's been
both my parents have been great partners
in helping me as well and that's so so
important to have people around you that
are supporting you yeah and i think as
well some people aren't so fortunate as
you some people their parents are and
then your mum's a bit skeptical but
sometimes they're like no you can't do
that you have to go to uni after and
they're really opposed and i always
think my best advice is don't tell your
parents what you're going to do
show them yeah just get results if
you're at university and they're like
and you're talking about wanting to
leave you name and they're going mad
don't leave una do property on the side
make some quick money and then when they
see the money coming in money talks man
yeah let them see your results don't
tell don't tell people what you're about
to do show them what you just did yeah
definitely 100 like
it's i it's a little bit different for
me so obviously
money definitely talks to my parents
they really get it um but for anyone out
there that's maybe thinking oh well i
don't know what so-and-so is going to
think maybe my friends might think
what you're doing that are you not just
coming to uni to do a business
management course or something like that
when really you can be going out and
making money and then when your friends
see the money and they'll go how did you
do that yeah i've had i've had i've had
some of that myself i've had all
what's rent to rent what's a lease
option kind of thing and it's well
you're the same people that were like
who's this samuel leeds guy kind of
thing right and they've seen the results
yeah also you've kind of developed a
little bit of reputation in huddersfield
yeah a little bit people know who you
are the property guy right so they're
letting agents but when people know who
you are and you you stop building a
reputation it snowballs right it gets
easier and easier yeah contacts make
contracts don't they absolutely love
that contacts make contracts love that
so what would be your best advice to
someone starting out maybe a teenager
and they're thinking oh i really got
much money and my parents aren't giving
me any money your parents didn't give
you any money either no you were a
teenager yeah what would be your best
advice
get educated i think do a crash course
learn what it's all about kind of and
based off that you can go all this
strategy is probably what i might excel
at and then just take action start
phoning agents start booking viewings
and stuff just comes off the back of
that as soon as you start viewing
meeting agents and getting familiar with
them they'll go well i've seen this and
this might be a good idea for you to
maybe have a look at to get started on
um but one thing i would say is don't
get disheartened early on yeah because
it will happen you will make the money
and once you get that first
three four hundred pounds maybe from a
rent to rent or that first couple of
grand from when you're selling a deal
um you'll get a really big buzz yeah and
then it'll just snowball like you said
you'll just really want to get going
you'll want to firm more agents you'll
want to go more places to do viewings
yeah and that's where you'll start
thinking okay i can build something big
here like an empire like you said yeah
another question for you what do you
think about paying for training
if you'd asked me this
um before i paid for any of the training
i would have gone oh well i don't know i
don't know too much maybe i have to look
into it more and then the more you say
that and the more that you kind of think
about it the less likely you are to do
it yeah
i went to a crash course the other day
and as soon as any advanced training was
brought up people run into the back of
the room to sign up for it and that's
the attitude that people need to have
because the training works it really
really really works yeah without that
without the training i would not be sat
here i'd probably at you i'd be at uni
with everyone else partying but instead
i'm getting up at 6am to go and do
viewings an hour away from where i live
and making money another thing you did
though that was really smart which i
know i told you to do this but you did
really well is you didn't rush in and
just pay for loads of courses all at
once no you watch the youtube videos put
some feeders out you then came to the
crash course you then bought a 1 000
online course yeah um
with the deal selling training you
managed to sell just one deal but one
deal is enough to pay back for the
training yeah more yeah and you kind of
just snowballed and as you got more
deals you invested more and now you're a
fully fledged academy member yeah but
you didn't just join the academy
straight away no no no you kind of built
up to it yeah and you know i really
respect that because i think that
if a teenager comes up to me and says
shall i get a loan
for 12 grand and put it and just do all
of the training i might be able
it's hard for me to say yeah do it
because i don't know how serious they
are i don't know if they're gonna
actually but i think if you start with
just a free course
then do just one course maybe invest a
thousand two thousand pounds but
probably no more than that and then just
slowly and then see if you can make the
money back yeah you know and slowly kind
of work your way up to it i think that's
probably the best advice i can give to a
teenager because at the end of the day
teenagers go to university to do
business degrees all the time yeah so if
you want to be a property investor
what we've got what we've set out is no
different really um and they're paid 27
grand for it over three years yeah
exactly and probably not being able to
become financially free in 12 months
like you've done no
so but everyone's different ultimately
and i think everybody has to make their
own lined up you were an adult when you
did the training you were you were 18
before you paid for any any training
yeah um started watching the videos at
17 but everyone everyone has to make up
their own mind but ultimately i think if
you want to get what most people can't
get in life then you need to do things
that they're not prepared to do yeah
that's what you've done yeah most people
aren't prepared to go to the crash
course spend their
little bit of money they've got on
training
speak to 20 30 agents and get rejected
yeah most people are not prepared to do
that you've done that and that's why
you've become financially free in 12
months yeah well hopefully this video
can inspire people
to
um or maybe push them to make that jump
and spend some money on some training
and then like you said it pays for
itself with one deal yeah that's it and
then not only have you paid off
that um money that you spent on training
but now you've got the knowledge and the
confidence to go do it again yeah and
also if if they're unsure start we've
come to the freeze training come down to
the crash course
what would you say you would say to
yourself going back say a year or two
what would be the best advice you'd give
to your site 18 month younger self
take action do something
it doesn't have to be a lot it could
even just start off by watching videos
or
reading a book like rich dad poor dad or
doing some
um streams that you do the uh online
courses or the crash courses that are
only a pound and then you put yourself
in that environment and it almost holds
you accountable to okay well i've spent
this time doing
this watching videos
doing the courses
let's see how i can implement it yeah
and get in contact with people that are
there as well especially if you've not
got that immediate um support around you
with family and friends
meet someone at the crash course talk to
someone and then maybe you can even do a
deal together kind of thing yeah yeah
that's so important also when you
first watch my videos i know you watched
like james armstrong yes on a wednesday
you saw a lot of people on when it's
wednesday did you think that you'd be
sat in my house within a year no not all
um it's quite surreal i remember driving
up to the house blah i've seen this in
so many videos it's great yeah um
uh but yeah watching people like james
especially because not only because he's
done so well but because of the age
thing as well it really um helped her
into me that oh well you can be
18 19 20 21 and without a lot of money
and still
go out and achieve and go out and work
really hard
and then you can be sat here making
videos meeting you yeah um coming to
your wonderful house meeting your lovely
family so and there's so many people now
that you know as well like james and all
these people on when it's wednesday you
now know the personally yeah yeah right
you're part of the environment you're
part of the club and um you know i
always say environment is stronger than
world power if you're trying to psych
yourself up at home on your own to do
stuff you sometimes you just won't do it
yeah because if you get what i said to
you earlier i was like 80 percent of
success showing up showing up what what
does that mean
it's like i was just saying going and
meeting people going to the crash
courses or if it's going and doing
viewings
or maybe even sat just looking at an
auction or something like that just
being there being in that environment
like you say
is so important to um meeting people or
making money like contacts make
contracts or you know show me your
friends i'll show you future kind of
thing see some people will say that you
got lucky but also actually tom didn't
get lucky tom created his own luck by
putting himself at the right place at
the right time which you've done so tom
respect brother i'm super proud of you i
know this is for you even though you're
financially free this is just the first
step
and you are gonna blow up so well done
thank you
guys i think you'll agree what an
absolutely incredible guy tom is do us a
favor smash the like button i think
you're going to see tom blow up massive
over these next few years so why don't
you drop a comment of support in the
comment box below also i've been doing
this for almost three years where i've
been interviewing one of my success
students who's become financially free
as a direct result of the training and
i've been doing this every single week
on winners on a wednesday so if you want
to see more interviews like this there's
way over 100 right up here over there
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel which you can do over here and
if you want to meet me personally at the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description and you
can come down for free see you soon god
bless peace
[Music]
you